Hello, world.
That was 2010.
It's been ten years since my first tweet.
Wait.
Why is the camera so close?
My seven favorite tweets of the past ten years.
This might be the most mind-blowing fact I learned this year.
I dumped ice water on my head to help raise awareness for ALS.
I often say vaccines are one of the best health investments.
There are few things I love talking about more than toilets.
I hate mosquitoes.
The diseases they spread kill more than half a million people every year.
In fact, mosquitoes kill more people in one day than sharks kill in 100 years.
I was touched when Melinda asked me to introduce her at her Moment of Lift book tour.
Who?
Oh, Bill.
Right, right.
Melinda's husband.
This is the most beautiful chart in the world.
Thank you Twitter for ten great years and here's to ten more.
Still feels like the camera is super close.